got a gun
dramatic body camera footage shows the
moments before California officers shoot
and kill an armed man after a foot chase
no don't pick it up don't pick it up
watch it watch it
stay on the ground
up don't do it the shooting happened on
December 20th of last year in
Bakersfield California about two hours
north of Los Angeles the Bakersfield
Police Department released the body
camera video just this month he's got a
gun the incident happened just before 10
o'clock in the morning when an adult man
was seen near the railroad tracks with a
weapon officers were in the area for an
unrelated call and responded to the
scene
body camera video highlights the suspect
allegedly showing a gun in his hand
officers fired shots but he ran off
suspects down make an entry team
from the West
Hub Medical Aid stage at Daniels
and Union
body camera video shows the suspect
running off as multiple officers follow
what's the crossbar
[Applause]
cucumber Chad
Bakersfield Police stop running
[Applause]
at the time there's conflicting reports
about whether the suspect has a knife or
a gun
a firearm
okay
Daniel
[Applause]
Chad
okay
officials later determined the suspect
had a gun during the initial shooting
but carried a knife as he led officers
on a chase
[Applause]
multiple units respond to the second
area where the suspect ran off to he's
right there
I got him
body camera video shows officers calling
for the suspect to drop the weapon when
he refuses they again open fire unit one
we got him he's walking towards us now
drop it
stop the dog
hold on bad drop bad drop
s
hey drop it drop it drop it
drop it
officers continue to yell for the man to
stop before firing even more shots
taking the shot taking the shot after
that they work to make sure the area is
clear watch his hands
watch his head
hey somebody grab
following the shooting officers provided
Medical Aid to the suspect but he died
on the scene in all eight officers fired
their weapons during the incident
I got a shot I got a shot
what time the Washington later
investigations found an unfired bullet
in the suspect's handgun that had a
possible firing pin strike on the primer
that means the trigger was pulled but
there was some sort of malfunction so
the Bullet never actually fired the
Bakersfield Police Department says the
shooting is still under investigation
right now the suspect's identity has not
been released reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie